hey it's midlay again
oh he likes to play this tricky
c5 line
okay we'll go into this
i looked this up right after i played
predki frankie played the same line i
didn't play e4 in that game
it was round one of abu dhabi
but engine i think it was close to equal
here so
it's playable
it just looks really wild
trying to like bluff that i actually
know what i'm doing all i know is g4 is
a move and
now i'm on my own and maybe he'll auto
resign
10 seconds from auto resigning
uh let's play this
move the point is if takes i take here
although i don't know if that's
working for me
it might not be
huh
take take
and this look this looks fun
[Music]
it might not work though
but it looks really fun
actually it might work
when i take the bishop i hit e7 and hit
the queen
i mean men lay usually beats me like 90
percent of the time
uh can i take the bishop here
now the knight's hanging up a piece here
actually
i was completely winning for white wow
i was beating one of the top gm's
at least in blitz on just.com in 14
moves
let's
go rhodes and beat men lay in 14 minutes
um
maybe he did
if eric should have become a gm i'm
guessing the reason eric didn't become a
gm is probably just like college school
all these other things yeah that's
i was such a cool game too i should show
man i should show a replay of that game
and just to actually show like i'll i'll
tell the whole story
so min lei played this agar matar
anti-london line
agar matra made a video about this a
while ago
and
generally i'm still comfortable here
because 93
but then when i went to abu dhabi
i played
uh alexander predki
who's top 50 in the world almost a super
gm
and
eric rosen london
grandmaster when i played trekkie under
predki uh who's the third seed in the
tournament almost a super gm yeah uh
he went into the same line
and
uh we got this position
and during the game
i i wasn't super well prepared i had
some like weird map but i had a weird
memory memory pop into my mind
uh from the time that i was teaching
alexandra botez the london andreas
actually and
i'm gonna have to dig up the the video
to see if i had shown her this position
but uh there's an idea here that i
wanted to play
but i couldn't remember if this was a
position
or not
but the idea is to play a very quick e4
and i'll just toggle engine analysis
uh to show
um and it looks actually to be playable
and the the point is after takes queen
e2
uh there's alignment on the e file and
if the knight moves and there's knight
takes d6 which is crushing for for white
uh so black would have to play f5 here
and um
i i considered this briefly during the
game but i just didn't have any
preparation in it or any memory of what
i had looked at
uh but apparently g4 and the position
gets crazy and maybe this is something i
can prepare
for the future if i want to have a
a much sharper position from early on
anyway so i got to play that
against midlay in this game
i mean g4 was the only thing i knew like
i should analyze a little bit further
but
at least uh the tactical motif is very
clear to undermine
uh the stability of black setup and then
go over this
um
eventual x-ray vision like pin thing on
the e-file
and
i essentially got what i wanted like i
was able to remove the knight
and
after i take the bishop the problem for
black is
if queen at four then i just meet
and if not queen f4
the queen's hit
this is hit this is hit
everything crumbles
so yeah
black resigned in this position
anyway um okay
i'm gonna wrap things up
thanks everyone for watching
uh hope people learned a thing or two